You've gotta be fast on your feet to keep up with Nintendo soccer!
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game played in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean. I'm Sam.
I'm Joe.
Joe, welcome again from...
Tel Aviv.
Tel Aviv!
That's where I am.
Sean always knows. How's the weather down there?
It's good. It's great.
What do I usually say? It's great.
Yeah, it's great. Joe, have you ever ran into Carmen Sandiego?
That's what I'm looking for.
That makes a lot of sense.
That would kill Sean for some reason.
That's good. As long as someone laughs at my bad jokes.
Yeah, I'll tell you though, since you're traveling, it's appropriate that we only play Nintendo
Soccer, otherwise just known as Soccer for the NES, because that has countries from all
over the world in it.
All over. Right.
It's everywhere. It's places such as the United States.
Yeah. Uh...
What are you pointing at me?
The Free Republic of Germany.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's got West Germany in it.
West Germany is in this game.
Um, and this game was made by Intelligent Systems, uh, which probably means nothing to
most people. To be honest, I'm a little worried if it actually is made by them.
Um, but I did a lot of research for this and it's listed on their website, but they swear
this game was made in 1986, which is impossible.
The copyright says 1985, but Intelligent Systems swears they made this game in 86.
But the reason why I even bring them up is because they're a big deal for Nintendo.
Uh, they're kind of like a second party developer for Nintendo.
They've made other games too, but they're responsible for the Fire Emblem series, the
Advanced Wars series, and the Paper Mario series.
So that's like three really solid series, even though unfortunately we haven't really
seen a great Paper Mario or a, uh, we haven't even seen an Advanced Wars in a while.
I'd just like to see that in general.
But that's, that's for a different kind of podcast.
It's a great pedigree. Yep.
Today we're talking about soccer.
Um, the game that people play in real life and, uh, you can also play on your NES.
So let's get some impressions.
Uh, yeah.
So my first impression with soccer was calm down soccer.
The music at this initial screen is like I'm at a carnival or something.
And I think Mike, I think it was you that said that you wanted some music, uh, during
baseball or during 10 yard fight.
That was absolutely me.
You got your wish because there is, there's definitely some, just some loud, crazy music
going on through this whole game.
Um, but also it, it, the game played like soccer.
I wasn't crazy about it, but I wasn't upset with it.
That was my initial impression.
All right, Sean. Sean. Okay.
Yeah. Um, the ridiculous nonstop backing music of this game, notwithstanding, I kind of like
soccer. And again, I'm the resident sports fan, uh, sports fan sports game fan.
Um, I had a lot of fun with soccer.
Um, I think it was, uh, the best representation of a physical sport, um, so far that we've played.
Um, maybe, maybe baseball's up there too, but you can't really feel, but like, I'm
like, um, I really liked all of the creative solutions to, um, how to represent certain
things in between passing, shooting, aiming, and all that fun stuff, dribbling.
Um, I really liked it.
Um, I don't know if y'all agree.
Thank goodness. You said physical sport because I was like how quickly we forgot golf, but not a physical
sport. So I'll allow it.
You know, you're talking about contact sports or whatever.
Uh, and my initial impression was I was happy with more options.
I thought that was kind of cool that you can actually choose a skill level, uh, something
we couldn't do in baseball or something we couldn't really do in 10 yard fight because
there was no difference between high school and super bowl really.
Um, and I also liked, uh, the ability to choose time too.
That was kind of cool. It's just way it was like, okay, I want to play a fast game or, you know, like there's
going to be an epic duel between me and my friend.
Once I actually started playing the game, my initial impression soured pretty fast.
I don't know if soccer is just not for me.
Full disclosure. I didn't grow up with any soccer.
My, my dad was not a soccer guy.
We never watched any.
I never really played any, but, um, I understand the rules and I just felt like ball handling
in this game in general, it's, it's, it's rough and I get it.
It's an NES launch game.
It has some limitations, but this is a little rougher than I expected it to be when I compared
to, um, you know, how fluid the passing was even in 10 yard fight.
Uh, granted there was an easy chance for an interception cause there was no Z axis, but
the past, which thankfully is in this game.
Yeah. I wasn't impressed with that too.
Uh, which I can't say so much here.
So my initial impression, not that great, Sam.
Yeah. Um, I'm kind of on the same page as Sean.
I think I, I've had a really nice little time with this one.
I thought that it felt the most like, uh, like my actions were controlling the game,
you know, which in a lot of the other sports games, I feel it didn't.
Um, I think that they, they got down a lot of different things.
You know, I feel like just the, the basic mechanics were pretty solid.
And after that, it was pretty, it was pretty simple.
You know, if anything, I would say it might be, it might be, well, I played on the easy
level. So it might be too easy on the easy level, which makes sense.
I felt just to chime in for a second.
I did feel like easy was too easy.
Yeah. I was up four goals before the second half.
Yeah. You can just kind of dribble at the goal and then shoot it at the goal and then you score.
Uh, but I thought it, it felt really solid.
I think the, uh, there is a, there's a difficulty progression between which, um, which setting
you use, which is nice to see.
And it, it actually like, it's one that you feel unlike, uh, like we said, 10 yard fight,
you can't really tell the difference.
Um, and yeah, like I jumped up from one to two.
It was still a little easy.
You got to three. It felt pretty good.
I tried four and they beat me.
So, um, I was, I was really impressed with this game.
I think that the rhythm of like just getting in the rhythm of running and dribbling and
trying to like deke your opponent out.
I know that Mike had a lot of problems, not problems, but you, you, you weren't a big
fan of how the controls felt.
Felt a little clunky. Yeah.
I thought they felt pretty good and just because soccer is a very stop and go.
Um, at least in the video game representations, cause you, you're always trying to catch up
to the ball. He just kicked.
Um, so I appreciate it.
I don't know if, if Sam or Joe feel that way at all.
Yeah. I thought that it looked clunky, but once you realize why, you know, like when you turn
and the ball turns with you, that's, that, that's just kind of the way, the best way.
I think that they could illustrate what's happening, but like, yeah, when a soccer player turns
and they have the ball, like they don't have, you know what I mean?
Like they can turn relatively easily.
It's not what it's going to look like the way it looked like in this NES game.
But once you kind of get past that, I think it felt good.
It just looked clunky.
The one clunky thing, uh, at least with the controls that I will seed, um, was the fact
that like, if you're controlling one of your defensemen and you're getting run up on, you
gotta be careful because not only are you controlling like your last defenseman, you're also controlling
your goalie, which screwed me up so much.
Like just the first time.
Like I was like, wow, I am not even near the net right now.
Like panic. There were a few times where I, I lost my goalie cause I was looking at my defensemen.
Exactly. Where'd my goalie go?
Once they get inside the box, that's when it changes your controls over.
Right, right. That's in the manual.
You are controlling, uh, both at once.
Really? I believe so.
Yeah. Okay. And, uh, it's also sort of the way that when you're on the attack, you're not only are
you, are you moving more towards the goal or setting up your play, but every time you press
up or down, you're also aiming your shot and it's sort of, it, it, it, it crosses over
so that it's possible to go from one corner to the other immediately and kind of, uh, get
the goalie, you know, in a weird position.
Um, I thought, I thought these are really interesting ways to solve these problems.
Um, they didn't always work the best.
Um, but I give them an A for effort.
Yeah. I think, uh, what I, I wanted to add the, uh, one of my favorite parts of the game was
when you score, your guys just go nuts.
They go nuts. And I love that.
The celebration is so cool.
The animations are so funny.
They're like, well, they're flapping their arms and everything.
It was great.
Is that, I don't even know what they're trying to simulate when they're flapping.
It's like, they're trying to look like birds or like the guy who scores does something
a little bit different too.
And it's just, I don't know.
It was just, it was really, it was a joy.
I would love to see a real soccer game in which they do that whenever they score.
I just kind of felt like, uh, you know, at any moment, the guy who scored was just
going to like slide on his knees, you know, like take his shirt off and be like, Oh my
God. Like, and there's a halftime show.
Yeah. Can we get to the halftime show?
Because. I love that.
First of all, I'm not sure if that happens in soccer.
Not that I know.
I don't watch a lot of soccer.
I've watched some, but even if there is like a halftime show, is it really just cheerleaders
that come out? Right.
I can't even think about it.
What I think is funny is that, I mean, the purpose of a halftime show is to like entertain
you while the game's not happening, but this is a video game.
You could just, the game could just start happening again.
I mean, I don't even know if you can skip it, but if you really miss a treat because like
these, these sprites are so poorly rendered.
I mean, like they, they look great.
I mean, I don't think they look great.
They look fine on the field as players, but like these, these cheerleaders look like the
scene in E.T.
where it puts the dress and wig on.
I didn't understand what they were going for with this.
Like just the shape of the head doesn't match the shape of the player's head.
The heads are very round on the cheerleaders.
They're very like oval shaped.
It was an odd decision.
I mean, but you know, character for the game.
Yeah. I actually kind of love the halftime show.
It cracks me up, but this is maximal soccer, right?
Uh, and also speaking of the sprites, I noticed that the, the goalie's sprite, his shirt and
his hair are reversed.
So if he had a red shirt, he'll have red hair and whatever color his hair was is his shirt
color. So I know that that's, I mean like technical answer.
That's a color limitation of the, but no, no, like it needed to be that way for the amount
of like different colors that you can fit in a, in a section of sprites.
Uh, but like, no, that's like a cool workaround.
No, I think that's a cool workaround.
Yeah. And also it's also appropriate for the game because it, when you're watching soccer, the
goaltender or the goalkeeper will usually be wearing a different Jersey just for everyone's
like, right. Just make sure everyone isn't confused as to who's who.
But could you not have just recolored the Jersey and left the hair?
So it didn't, so people didn't have blue colored hair or that's kind of, that's what
Mike's saying. I think that they didn't want to have the hair and the Jersey be the same exact color.
Right. Yeah.
That makes sense. Yeah. Uh, so since we're on the topic of the goalies though, I just wanted to talk about what I
think is the best aspect of this game.
And that's the shooting the goal.
Like it's very intuitive, uh, as opposed to the passing, which I felt was kind of like,
yes, you can control it a little bit, but I felt like nine times out of 10, if I'm passing
that ball, it's like, good luck.
Yeah. It was a very rudimentary version of like in FIFA.
You could just like press the analog stick in a direction and it'll say like this, this
is probably the player trying to pass to and it'll go there.
Whereas in this one, you kind of cycle through highlighted characters or highlighted players.
And I mean, it, it was a good idea.
It wasn't the best execution, but it was an execution.
It was an execution.
It was, it was 99 times out of the 10, like if you, if you played enough of the game, you'll
get, you'll pass to the correct player.
Um, but yeah, the shooting is definitely more intuitive than the passing.
Um, just because I like, I like that arrow, you know, like the ability to kind of say like,
this is where I'm going to shoot and stuff like that.
And having some control over that kind of brings me back to like with golf where you
had the power meter and it's like give control over your swing.
It's not just like, yeah, all right, here I go.
I'm about to take a big swing.
You know, it's like, I can control how much I want to take of this swing.
Similar to how, like what we wished in baseball or football, if you could say like, I want
to throw to this guy in football or in baseball, I want to swing this hard.
Like, uh, the, the one part that, uh, it kind of is counterintuitive is it really telegraphs.
If you're playing two players, it really telegraphs where you're going to shoot the ball.
Um, but I think that a workaround is the fact that, um, where you're shooting isn't really
bounded. If you hit the top corner or if you move towards the top corner and you keep going, you will go
back to the bottom corner and maybe throw, throw your, uh, your opponent on.
Speaking of multiplayer, I think personally, that's, that's where I find the most enjoyment
out of this game as someone who, I'm not a big, you know, sports game fan anyways.
So I would just rather be competing with someone.
So I kind of just went to, I played one, one match against the computer on easy mode.
And then I just went straight to playing against another real player, which I found more fun.
Yeah. You have so many friends, Joe.
Yeah. Um, no, me and, uh, me and Mike were playing, uh, against each other earlier.
Yeah. And I think that brings up a good point about defense.
So I felt like offense.
Okay. There's something.
Give me something. Defense on the other hand, it's pretty hard.
Yeah. I wish there was some kind of like slide animation to kind of kick the ball out or even just some
option to kind of like try to steal the ball.
Similar to like what there was in, I mean like this game came much later, but like NBA
Jam lets you like take, yeah, like take the ball from basketball from the other team.
There's just something like that.
It's definitely a weird feeling playing a soccer game without a slide button.
Yeah. I was missing that.
Yeah. Um, but these games, uh, can be pretty tense.
And like, I think, uh, the, it really comes to a head.
If you end up tied at the end of the game, uh, it doesn't go to extra time and it doesn't
just end like in a 10 yard fight.
Baseball. Yeah.
Or in baseball. Or it just ends in a tie.
I'm so mad about that.
Um, luckily we get a shootout where it kind of changes the mechanics of shooting, um, where
you'll rob to the ball and you don't get a, you don't get an arrow pointing to where you're
going to shoot because your opponent, if you're playing a real person, uh, will be the goalie.
Uh, you just, you just point in a direction and that's where you shoot the ball.
I think like it's, uh, if you've been playing competitively against each other and you get
to a shootout, it can be a really tense and, uh, either, uh, euphoric or very, um, frustrating
moment. Yeah.
So I'm glad you brought that up.
Cause I think that's a natural segue to another feature of the game, which is the penalty
kick. I think that's really cool that they put that in there as like a tiebreaker, uh, on baseball.
Sam was kind of talking about how his game ended in a tie.
Yeah. I was off to a great comeback and I just had to hold them for the last inning and I did.
And then, and you were rewarded with a tie.
Yeah. I didn't get the chance to redeem myself.
Uh, so did anybody get to penalty kicks?
No, I haven't either.
No, me and Sean in our game got to it.
What were we saying, Joe? No, I'm just saying I, I didn't, I, to be honest, I didn't play as much as seems like
as you guys did. I played, like I said, I played the one game against a computer and one or two games against
a friend and that was kind of it.
So I think you guys maybe have a little more say about, uh, something, stuff I might've
missed. Right, right, right.
Uh, yeah, me and Sean actually got to it in our game.
Uh, it was tense.
I missed every single shot.
Um, Sean is an excellent, uh, goalkeeper and he really can read where things are going to
go. So I continued to move to the right and he would shoot to the left every single time.
Uh, I got closer and closer to blocking it each time, but, uh, Sean walked away handedly,
uh, the three nothing shootout after a one, one tie.
So, um, I think that's just like a really cool thing to program into the game cause it's an
extra step. Yeah.
Uh, one other quick thing that I have is these, these other prior sports games.
Like I don't think there was any way to play it wrong.
Like you couldn't get a penalty in 10 yard fight.
You couldn't hit the, uh, the batter in baseball golf.
You could get out of bounds.
That's kind of playing the game wrong.
Um, but this is the first sport game that I've seen.
Like you can get off sides or you can, um, like it will punish you in the way that is
like it would be in the game.
Like you get throw ins if you could get out of bounds.
Whereas like, I think in a less, uh, a, a less, uh, technologically sound game, it would
just have, you can't kick it out of bounds.
Right. Yeah. It would almost be like a border wall.
Yeah. And the, the offsides surprised me actually.
Cause I, I guess for some reason I just thought that like this game wouldn't be able to handle
the idea of offsides.
And then when I, like, and then when it happened, I was like, Oh, they programmed that in
like, yeah.
Yeah. That's the first we've seen of that level of.
And I didn't have like corner kicks or goal kicks or anything, but I know those are in
it. Yeah. They definitely exist in the game.
Um, and I have like throw ins and everything.
Yeah. We're at it. We're at an interesting, very complete.
We're at an interesting point, um, in the NES launch games where we've seen Irem make 10
yard fight and Kung Fu.
We've seen Nintendo make a bunch of games, but also a game like baseball.
And now we're seeing, uh, a different, you know, kind of entry with intelligent systems
making soccer.
And while I agree that like, you know, I love the extra options and I definitely think it's
a more like realistic take than say baseball because it couldn't, you couldn't field or
10 yard fight. Because if you went like two steps back, you all of a sudden were kicking a punt and it's
like, well, I don't think that's what happens when I, when I want to like get away from a,
you know, a defender.
Um, but I think that's cool.
Uh, but I will say that sometimes, you know, especially with these NES games, less is more.
And, and I liked, I liked baseball and you know, this might just come down to a sports
preference, but I liked baseball, uh, more than this, even though it was lacking some
features just because I felt like, you know, to Sean's point, minimalist baseball, this
was like, there's a lot going on here.
And I don't know if I need all of it.
I don't know if I need the offsides in an early soccer game.
Like, and I didn't kill the game for me first off, cause that's a stupid complaint.
Okay. Like, like offsides is a rule in soccer and should be in the game.
I'm just saying is it's a noticeable design difference between the two.
Yeah. Well, well, even, uh, even, uh, I noticed that like the sprites, I didn't really notice
the similarities in a lot of the sprites of the games we were playing before until I played
soccer and I was like, the sprites look different.
They look, they're like, they're bigger and a little more detailed, I guess.
Uh, and they dance, but like they're, they dance.
Yeah. But like the, yeah, they, you can, I know, now that I'm looking back at it, I can kind
of tell that like the sprites and 10 yard fight and the sprites and baseball were like,
well, actually they weren't made by the same person or they, no, no, they were not.
But, um, 10 yard fight, especially 10 yard fight has like really small people, Joe.
I don't know if you're remembering that correctly, but it was like, they're like dots.
Yeah. Baseball did too, didn't it?
Or baseball is the one I don't remember as much, but.
No, baseball had like, I mean, again, smaller than soccer, but they were okay.
Uh, 10 yard fight was like football for ants.
Right. Uh, all right.
So with, with that, let's get into the essential games list.
All right.
It's the essential games list.
You know what that is.
We're going to vote on whether this game is essential, uh, today.
So not like, was this a good NES game when it launched?
We don't care about that.
It's 2018.
We're going to treat this game like 2018.
That means that we think a game like duck hunt is still worth playing in 2018, but you're
looking through your steam catalog right now and you're seeing a game like football manager
and you're like, Oh, should I ruin my life with a 500 hour long game?
Like football manager that never ends.
And I'm going to start missing breakfast over this.
And you're like, huh?
Or maybe I just go out and get a cheap copy of soccer for the NES and see if that could
fulfill my needs of not having to go outside and kick a ball for real.
Definitely. Yeah.
Sean, this, this game, it, I guess this can be seen as a flaw, uh, to, to some people at
this podcast, but I think in terms of, uh, the level of simulation, this blows, um, this
blows 10 yard fight out of the water on the American football version.
Um, I, I kind of see 10 yard fight as a lesser game after playing this one.
Um, just because I didn't think it was going to be this in depth.
Um, but I really enjoyed playing it.
I liked my time with it.
Uh, that said, this is, this is sort of like the, the, the most common reason for like these
games, like this is a sports game.
Go back and play this.
If you are a sports game fan or a soccer, if you're a FIFA fan, play this, play this game.
Everybody else, you don't need to play this game.
This is not essential. I would, I would like to add though, for a second, because we have been using this, uh,
thing. And I'm just going to say though, just because you like FIFA 18 doesn't mean that you should
go back and play this game.
It's more like just the idea that you're listening to this and you're interested in like what this
old soccer game was like, we're kind of just throwing it out there.
Like, Hey, it's not, it's not going to hurt you to try it.
Yeah. You know, but I think that if you can't play the FIFA games, you're not going to like this
game. No, I don't know.
I, my take on this is that it's more like, like, yeah, they did try and do a bunch of
different cool things like throw-ins and gold kicks and corner kicks and penalty kicks and
all this stuff. But so did backyard soccer for the computer.
And I, I think that game is, is way better, you know?
So if I had the choice between those two gamer, yeah, go ahead.
Yeah. I mean, for me, for me, it's not essential just cause I think backyard soccer.
Cause backyard soccer, if you want to play a game that's realistic to soccer, then you're
going to play FIFA. And if you want to play a game that is more arcadey and kind of very basic, you're going
to play backyard soccer cause it's cause you got Pablo Sanchez in there and he's the best.
Uh, but, um, uh, but this game is, it's kind of both and neither of those things in that
it's, it kind of feels very arcadey and just kind of it's, I mean, it's very basic just
cause it's NES and they can't do a lot.
Uh, but they're trying to do a lot with it too, which is what kind of what Sean was saying
earlier. I just think that you can, you can find something that's more your speed depending on which way
you go. If you like the more kind of, kind of silly aspect of it, then you play backyard soccer.
Pablo Sanchez and Ricky Johnson.
All right. Dante Robinson is your goalie.
Okay. Joe. Yeah.
I mean, I, I kind of going back to what my initial impression was like this game, well,
besides the music, but this game works.
So it's, I think it was moderately fun.
If you like, like Sean and Sambo said, like, if you, if you like soccer, you'll probably enjoy
this game personally.
It wasn't really for me.
And even if you're a big soccer fan, I wouldn't say this is absolutely essential.
I just think it's worth playing if you're a soccer fan, but that's, that's really about
it for me. Like I said, I didn't get as much out of it as you guys seem to have.
So that's about all I got to say.
No, I definitely didn't get much out of it either, Joe.
Uh, and for that reason, it's not in my essential games list.
Um, just to get into it a little further, if I could add an additional thought here is
that when I say, do these games hold up today?
I don't mean like, can you still play it?
Because yeah. And I'm not saying you guys said that, but I mean like, yeah, any of these games, you
could still play, but like, there's so many, uh, so many things to expand on here and so
many ways to improve the controls, such as like an analog stick.
Like, I just feel like the D pad alone and like its limitations have kind of made this
game a little less playable today.
And so that's why it doesn't enter the essential games list.
You know, we were talking about like duck hunt and the zapper and the fluidity of that and
how it still works in 2018.
I think that's like something special, you know?
And that's like kind of what the essential games list is reserved for.
And so I don't think a game like soccer, you know, ever has a chance of getting a yay
from me. Uh, but I'm very tough.
Uh, you know, people have said.
I think we're all pretty, people have said.
People have said, I'm the toughest.
Um, so, so, you know, yes, it's a no, uh, and who knows if any other soccer game on the
NES will be deemed a part of my essential list or any sports game for that matter.
So far, haven't been too jazzed on those sports games, but I haven't thrown any in my jank
folder either. So there's that.
Uh, can I just say one, one thing that I, that I meant to say in my, uh, recap there
was that I, uh, I do appreciate that even though I didn't really play it, I do appreciate that
you guys are saying that there are different levels of difficulty.
Um, because I do feel like this is a game that you could, if you were, if you are a soccer
fan, you could play over and over again and actually get better at and work your way up,
which is something that 10 yard fight didn't really have and baseball didn't have.
Um, so that is something that I do think puts it a little above, at least in that, uh, aspect
of things. It's something it's got that the others don't still not essential.
Right. I think they all fulfill a different, a different kind of need, but 10 yard fight fulfills the
least amount of needs.
Yes, I agree. Uh, all right.
And that's all the time we have for this episode of nostalgia.
Join us next time for stack up and be sure to play it yourself.
Yeah, Rob, uh, for more nostalgia, for more nostalgia, please subscribe to our podcast
wherever you listen and be sure to check out nostalgia cast.com.
That's N E S T A L G I A cast.com.
There you'll find links to the show notes as well as, uh, our Twitch, Twitter, YouTube,
Facebook, you name it.
We got it on there. Thank you so much for your support of nostalgia.
We thank you for spending time with us.
I'm Michael Esposito.
You can find me on ad Esposito film on Twitter, and I'll talk to you soon. Bye.